Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is 2192. David P. Increasingly,
people in the audience are very concerned
about mypillow CEO Mike Lindell's health.
Speaker 6: We're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: We have all noticed that he seems
particularly hopped up lately. And here is a
caller who says Pillow is sick. Pillow is sick.
Speaker 3: Hi, David. In lieu of last night's,
hopefully one of the final hearings of January two
six. Yeah, I was hoping that you might really go a
little bit lighter on Mike Lindell. The man is
ill, and I don't want to see him harm himself.
And we need to has compassion as we can for him.
Hopefully he's going to realize what's going on
and he's going to do a big one, Katie. And
I think the man is going to need support.
Well, yeah, the country hasn't actually made fun
of him for snapping. And we need to shape up as
human beings and realize that he's one of us,
in spite of the fact we're he's just sick and
we need to take care of him. Thanks, Mike.
Speaker 1: There is no question whatsoever
that something is very wrong with Mike
Pillow. Now, there has been speculation
that he's back on drugs. I don't know if
that's the case. It's not funny. It's sad.
It's a medical problem. And he needs help. There
is speculation that this insanity over the last
two years of flying all around the country at
every Trump rally and doing his CBS.com and all
of these different things has just strained his
relationship with his family. And that that's kind
of what we are seeing. Something is very clearly
wrong with the guy. And early on we would wonder,
does Mike Pillow believe this stuff or doesn't
he? And at first I thought at first I thought
it was sort of an act. It doesn't seem like an
act at this point. And I interviewed him and I
interacted with him a little bit behind the scenes
and also saw how he interacts with his staff.
Something seems off with the guy. So, listen,
I hope he gets the help that he needs. We will
to the extent that he still has a following. I
mean, listen, as I've said before, when you've
got a crazy guy yelling in the subway and they
don't have the following to become president
or become adjacent to the president, you don't
think about it too much when you have a country
that will see a guy who is so obviously unhinged
and say, this guy is a genius, this guy is going
to save us. And then the former president invites
him to his rallies. Or maybe he's not invited, but
welcomed and shouted out. Then you say it's more
about the followers than it is the guy. And that
certainly seems to be the case with Mike Pillow.
So hopefully he gets the help he needs. It seems
like it's a lot of it. We have a great bonus
show planned for you today. A Republican lawmaker
voted against same sex marriage and then three
days later went to his gay son's gay wedding.
What? Yeah. Russia says it will
quit the International Space Station
after 2024. And the teen activist who was body
shamed by Republican Congressman Matt Gaetz,
has received more than $28,000 in donations for
her work. Three incredible stories, all on today's
bonus show. You can sign up at. Join Pacman
scum. Get instant access. We will see you then.